Okay,
I'm going to do the official introduction.
I'm how very,
I'm the chief economist here.
I think many of you know me,
Glenn Wiles of principal researcher at Microsoft is,
sorry,
eight principal researcher at Microsoft Research New England.
And this year he's visiting Yale University as a senior research scholar and
lecture in the Economics Department and the law school where he teaches a joint
economics computer science course called designing the digital economy.
Glen is a townie.
He grew up in Palo Alto,
received his Ab and economics or Princeton,
followed by an MBA and a phd in 2008.
He then spent three years as a junior fellow at the Harvard Society of fellows
in three years as an assistant professor at the University of Chicago before
joining Microsoft.
And uh,
over the period from 2014 to 2018,
he's a,
he's been a Sloan research fellow and today he's here to tell us about his book,
radical markets,
uprooting capitalism and democracy for a just society.
Take it away.
Thanks.
Hello.
And thanks to everyone for coming.
So,
um,
this work is the culmination of many years of sort of careful policy design
research with Eric Posner.
Um,
but,
uh,
in the 10 minutes I have to introduce it.
I think rather than going into the details of all of the proposals that we have,
it's best to just give you a flavor of the,
the sort of broad idea that we're trying to get across.
And I think that that's best conveyed by a thought experiment.
So I want you to,
for the moment,
suspend your practical considerations and come with me on a journey of
imagination to a fictive city that I'm in a call market topia.
So Market Topia is a bit like Zootopia,
except rather than being defined by having a diverse group of mammals that
inhabited instead market topia is defined by the fact that all the major,
uh,
private property in a market Topia um,
let's put aside personal effects like,
you know,
uh,
heirlooms and pets and so forth.
But all the land and the houses and the airplanes and so forth is continually up
for auction to the highest bidder in a manner somewhat similar to the way that
search terms are for Google a advertisements.
So,
um,
basically,
uh,
whoever is currently the highest bidder on one of these,
pieces of private property controls it for the time being by making a rental
payment continually into a central pot until someone else comes along and beats
their price and takes over that payment for control of that asset.
And that's not just true of private property in a market.
Topia in fact,
many things that we would usually consider to be determined by collective
decision making processes like the,
um,
the,
uh,
location of parks and,
the politicians that govern market topia.
Uh,
what sort of schools they have and what they teach and so forth.
These are also determined by an auction process though rather than a auctioning
them to the highest bidder.
We add up the total willingness of everyone to pay for different alternatives
and we implement the one that people are willing in total to pay the most for.
And all of the money that's raised by these auctions is continually return to
all the citizens of market Topia in equal shares as a social dividend or you
might call it a universal basic income.
Much as in Norway and Alaska.
When they auction off oil rights,
they return the revenue that they raise to the citizens.
Okay.
Now when you hear this idea of market,
Toby,
it might sound like sort of the most extreme version of a free market that you
can imagine.
It's sorta like much crazier than anything that say Adam Smith could have
imagined.
Um,
because it makes you realize that even though we live in a market society,
most things are not available for liquid purchase at any given point in time.
You know,
most of the land on the Google campus,
uh,
most of the stock of Google,
in fact,
not just the,
the marginal units of stock that are currently on bid,
but most of the stock that all of you hold,
these aren't things you could just go out and buy it some price at any point in
time.
Um,
those are instead controlled by often wealthy concentrated interests.
And if you wanted to grab control of those assets,
you'd have to enter into a long and drawn out process of bargaining and probably
pay many times what the person would be willing to accept as they get wind that
you'd want to buy that thing.
Right?
And so market Topia is a far more extreme,
complete free market than any,
uh,
society,
in history.
Um,
and that might lead you to think,
okay,
so in market Topia the wealthy are going to dominate everything,
right?
The wealthy are going to be able to outbid the prices that anyone else is going
to pay.
They're going to take control of assets and they're going to use that to
dominate everyone else in society.
But then you asked to ask yourself,
what do you mean by the wealthy?
Well,
a wealthy person is someone who has lots of assets like stocks and bonds and
houses and land and businesses,
right?
But in market topia there is no private ownership of those things.
All of those things are auctioned for the public benefit.
In fact,
market Topia is actually sort of the most extreme version of the sort of common
ownership advocated by people like Karl Marx that you can imagine much more
extreme than forms of socialism that actually existed,
which ended up in the control of those assets by a concentrated bureaucratic
elite that often ended up tyrannizing over the rest of the population even more
intensely than the capitalists that they claim to replace.
Um,
in market.
Toby,
on the other hand,
there is true common ownership because by construction,
all the value of all assets flow equally to all citizens.
And by construction,
every citizen has an equal right to compete for control of assets.
So this might seem like a paradox,
especially to those of us who grew up in the cold war and post Cold War periods.
How can,
like the most extreme form of common ownership of sort of communism go along
with the most extreme form of a free market?
Well,
while that might seem like a paradox,
it's actually,
uh,
a crucial part of what was the central tradition in a field called political
economy that gave birth to economics,
political science,
um,
sociology in many other fields during the late 19th century.
And,
uh,
this idea called competitive common ownership was especially associated with the
work of this guy here.
Um,
and I wonder if anyone recognizes him.
Who is that?
Well,
this is the first time anyone has actually managed to identify head.
I'm,
I'm glad I came to the right place
so you could probably repeat the following things for me.
But Henry George was,
um,
uh,
the bestselling author in the English language other than the Bible for about 30
years.
His book progress and poverty was the namesake of the progressive movement,
uh,
in the United States.
He helped inspire the Chinese nationalist revolution and many other things.
So he's an enormously influential person.
And yet his ideas are largely forgotten in the post Cold War era.
And the goal of this book is to revive the tradition,
uh,
that was represented by Henry George and others like Leon Vol,
Ross,
many of the founders of modern economics who believed that free market,
true free markets and true socialism went hand in hand.
And,
uh,
to argue that while these ideas were forgotten in mainstream culture,
they continued to be developed in a field called mechanism design,
which a one,
lots of Nobel prizes but was largely applied,
um,
to things like auctioning off search words that,
uh,
you know,
companies like Google and Facebook rather than to the big problems of social
organization.
And to show that we can,
based on this tradition,
have a new way of organizing society to address our most pressing problems.
Um,
and the way that we do that is by developing five detailed practical policy
proposals,
building off of this spirit,
um,
that,
uh,
instantiate this idea and address,
um,
we think some of the most pressing problems of inequality,
a slow growth and,
um,
uh,
social conflict over political issues.
So what are those ideas?
Um,
the first,
which is most closely associated with this auction I was describing is the
common ownership self assess tax in which every owner of significant private
property would self assess the value of that property at some value stand
willing to sell the property at that value and then pay a tax on that self
assessed value.
So this would be a way of implementing the auction that I was describing without
taking all ownership into the public so that people would still have some
incentive to make investments.
Um,
do I turn off this?
so people would still have an incentive to make investments,
uh,
and uh,
at the same time,
all assets would be liquidly available for turnover to a better potential use.
The second idea is quadratic voting.
This is a system of sort of auctioning,
but for collective decision making that would protect minorities by allowing
them to express the greater strength of their interest in given issues,
uh,
compared to majority's,
the way that it would work is that every citizen would be endowed with a budget
of voice credits that they could spend on different politicians or issues.
Uh,
in a referenda that are important to them.
Um,
and they could put more votes on the issues that were more important to them,
but according to a very particular rule,
which is that the cost invoice credits of influence on any given issue would be
the square of the number of votes that you buy on that issue.
Um,
third,
we propose a new system of migration in which immigration would benefit rather
than just the immigrants and the capitalists in the wealthy countries.
Instead,
it would immigrant,
uh,
it would,
benefit all citizens because rather than large corporations or governments
determining who was admitted to the country,
instead,
individual citizens would have the right to sponsor visas for migrants and to
negotiate subject to some protections,
a share of the benefits that the migrants received from migrating to wealthy
countries.
Um,
so that would allow for massively increased migration.
But with the broad support of the working classes of wealthy countries.
Fourth,
we argue that antitrust policy is an incredibly powerful tool for maintaining a
competitive and dynamic economy.
But that it has been almost completely unenforced in the two most important
areas in which market power is accumulating in our economy.
And therefore we've been ignoring about 80% of the or night,
maybe even 90% of the potential benefits of antitrust.
Those two areas are that first of all,
institutional investors like vanguard,
state street,
blackrock,
etc. Now control about a third of the total corporate economy and are the four
or five largest shareholders of almost every major corporation,
uh,
straight across industries,
Google and Microsoft,
American Airlines and Delta.
And therefore they have no interest in seeing these companies compete with each
other.
And we've seen rising prices in re in coral close correlation to the growing
power of these companies.
Um,
so that's sort of the most comprehensive market power that's ever existed
because it's coordinated almost the entirety of the corporate economy.
Um,
another area that's been almost completely neglected by antitrust policy has
been the power that companies have over workers rather than over consumers.
Because,
uh,
if you think about,
you know,
a typical consumption decision you make,
like what type of water to drink?
There's probably 10 or 15 reasonable alternatives you have.
Whereas if you think about job,
what's your next best job rather than working at Google,
it's probably a way worse option.
And maybe you have one other option,
but uh,
but it's,
you know,
much harder,
much less competitive than is a typical a product market.
And yet there's literally never been an antitrust merger case for that blocked
the merger because of the way it reduced options for employment for workers.
And finally,
we argue that the individual contributions that people make to the digital
economy should be treated as a label,
as essentially labor.
And that there should be a labor movement that of people who are contributing
that data to uh,
organize to demand a fair share of the value created by their data from
companies like Google,
Facebook and Microsoft.
Because increasingly people are worried about artificial intelligence taking
people's jobs.
But as all of us here know that all that artificial intelligence is trained
based on human data and it's in fact a lot more like a,
some sort of broadcasting of our data than it is just brilliant engineers,
programming computers to go and take people's jobs.
And so,
uh,
if people were more fairly compensated for their data,
the digital economy would be a source of economic opportunity for people rather
than,
uh,
an economic threat.
Now,
all of these ideas are quite radical.
All of them would require fundamental changes to our social institutions.
And while for each of these chapters,
we have concrete near term noncontroversial steps we can make in that direction.
Um,
we also know that as a broad social philosophy,
no one would seriously consider this if we weren't in a moment of social crisis
that really deeply required new out of the box thinking like this to avoid
potentially catastrophic outcomes.
But I truly do believe we are in a moment like that for three reasons.
One,
uh,
is growing inequality.
So on the left here we see a graph of the share of national income,
uh,
accruing to the top 1% in top 0.1% of the income distribution,
which has doubled since the 1970s.
And at the same time we've seen a dramatic reduction in the share of income
accruing not just to lower income workers but to all workers in total.
So the share of income being paid out to labor as opposed to capital has fallen
by 10% over this period.
Now you might think,
uh,
as say Ronald Reagan or Margaret Thatcher would have argued that,
well that might be worth it if that's the price of a more dynamic,
more competitive,
more innovative economy.
But at the same time that we've seen this declining share going to labor,
we've seen an increasing power of corporations to exert monopoly power.
Um,
so that is represented by this orange line here.
I've taken the markup that firms charge.
That is how much above their marginal costs they charge.
And I've flipped it around so you can see how closely it parallels the decline
in labor incomes.
So that strongly suggests that far from US getting a more competitive economy by
deregulating cutting taxes and,
you know,
relaxing antitrust policy,
we've actually seen an increasing growth of market power,
um,
that is actually reducing,
uh,
growth rates in the economy as represented in this graph here.
So what this shows is a growth rates in different,
uh,
wealthy countries in the immediate post war period,
and then various periods thereafter.
And the period of the last,
uh,
you know,
several decades has had growth rates that are in the United States about half
and in many other wealthy countries,
about a 10th of what they were in the immediate post war period.
Um,
so this combination of stagnation with growing inequality,
I think has largely discredited existing economic ideologies as coming out of
Reagan and Thatcher in the same way that the stag,
the combination of stagnation and inflation during the 1970s discredited the
previous Keynesian Orthodoxy.
And this stagnant quality is,
we label it.
And the discrediting of existing economic ideologies has also led to rising
political discontent and conflict,
um,
together with the fact that I think,
uh,
political institutions,
not just economic,
uh,
technocracy,
but political technocracy is increasingly being viewed as illegitimate.
There's a growing conflicts between minorities and majorities,
whether over immigration,
uh,
ethno racial conflict or over a say things like gun ownership,
religious minorities.
And yet the way that a wealthy countries have increasingly resolve these issues
has been through the judiciary,
uh,
or through supernational institutions in the case of the European Union that
lack the democratic legitimacy needed for countries to come to some reasonable
way of resolving this.
So there's an increasing feeling that the economic policies and the way that we
resolve political disputes are illegitimate,
and that's leading to the rise of populous leaders,
whether on the right like Trump or Brexit,
mu,
uh,
a movement or on the left like Jeremy Corbyn in the United Kingdom.
So,
um,
given all this,
I think we increasingly feel like the only path out is these sort of reactionary
populous movements that don't really offer an answer.
And so we feel the responsibility at this moment to try to put forward an
alternative,
progressive path that can harness the powers of marketing and technology,
but to try to make a more equal,
a prosperous and politically a cooperative society.
And,
uh,
I hope that you'll open your minds to these radical possibilities,
given what we're facing.
And I'm looking forward to chatting with all of you and with Hal about it.
All right,
great.
Very interesting talk and let me raise a few objections here and there because I
know that she's your favorite pastime is responding to these objections.
You know,
they say a cynic believes that everything has a price,
but an economist knows it's true.
So one interesting angle there on that,
a division dividing things up with them,
letting people trade.
Um,
what do you do about the ability?
The ability is very tricky because suppose you're a great singer.
I love to hear you sing.
Yeah.
But it's very tiring for you.
You don't want to do it.
Can I outbid you and say yes,
I bid him.
He wants to have a quiet evening at home.
But I've got this money,
I'm going to pay him to go out and say it.
So that that's a,
that's a great question.
We tackle in the conclusion
of the book for the main part of the book,
we only allow for capital to be allocated in this way and we think that at least
in our present society that could address much,
uh,
of the inequality though not all of the inequality that we face.
So we calculate that with our reforms.
You could get down below the levels of inequality in the 1970s and a
significantly better than in Sweden that president,
but obviously there would then be a shift towards inequalities that are driven
more by ability and away from those driven by wealth.
And,
uh,
those would have to be addressed by future reforms.
And we speculate in the direction that you're describing how,
but we,
we,
we don't have a proposal that we're happy with,
uh,
actually putting forward,
I'm not sure,
let me suggest an article.
It was something I wrote.
It was my thesis actually,
which was odd fair division.
Oh,
I know that.
We're very,
well,
there were a couple ideas there about how you might deal with this issue of
either redefining what would it be fair when there's differences in ability or
in fact going the very radical plan of actually I could outbid you to sing.
And uh,
yeah,
so I'm actually doing it sympathetic to that idea,
but for a bunch of practical reasons,
we talked about in the conclusion we don't think we have a proposal that
actually makes sense,
but as a philosophical level,
you'll recognize your own writing in what we say about that issue.
So
it's also interesting because there is a practical example.
There were apprenticeships.
Yeah.
So what happened in America,
I mean before there was the United States,
in fact,
back in,
uh,
pre-revolution days,
you could bring an immigrant in and the quid pro quo is it worked for you for
seven years and you would teach them a trade.
And so this was viewed as a very successful way to provide education and skills
and so on.
I wouldn't say that too loudly because on the Internet when we certainly weren't
advocating indentured servitude,
but we just talked about our immigration system,
which is not indentured servitude.
We got the most crazy reaction,
uh,
from social media.
So it's a sensitive subject.
Yes,
yes,
I agree.
And it's also illegal.
Yes.
They're self assess tax.
I was kind of fun.
I first heard this idea from Dixie cows or you know,
many years ago about,
and he claims that the Greeks used as for assessing.
Yeah,
we talked about in chapter one some detail.
Yeah.
And in fact we did something very much like it for the top level domain names
when we had this top level domain name auction.
So Microsoft and Google for example,
both my one dot doc as a TLD.
And uh,
the way it was resolved is you each write down your price.
The high bidder gets it then pays the other bidder,
the,
the price that it,
that it bid.
So it's a,
it's a kind of interesting mechanism.
It's not of course perfect the lea,
anybody,
any economist that shoots a Molson it.
But it seemed to work pretty well in practice.
Um,
these's data as labor.
What we do that now we'd pay labelers of data.
We have just donated 9 million images to the open image project that we paid
lots of people around the world to label that data with the contents.
Uh,
we did the same thing,
4.5 million youtube videos,
which we had people label and that goes into the video project,
uh,
consumer panels like Nielsen that's around all the time.
So there is a market for getting people to provide data labeling or data of one
sort or another.
I said it's not a reasonably,
I mean it's a pretty big market reading.
Yeah.
I think that the problem is that the vast majority of data we get,
we collect from people who aren't aware of the productivity roles that it ends
up playing that and trying to engage those people more and paying them a bit
more for this people who are in context who can provide additional value.
And in fact,
Google does a little bit of that with the local hosts,
uh,
and so forth.
But,
uh,
but I think trying to make people more broadly aware of that and trying to
create a structure where they would get direct compensation for improving the
quality of the data they provide and be aware of the payments they were getting
for all of their data.
Would in the medium term create,
uh,
the opportunity for people to build greater,
human capital really and,
uh,
contribute more online?
Well,
there is this question of what the payment would look like if you take Facebook
as an example,
cause I think you've mentioned this,
a Facebook had net earnings of a 10 billion and they claim they're 2 billion
users and that means $5 a year per user.
So mean Google has similar numbers of course.
So these work out to pennies per day in terms of the compensation for
information that people are providing.
An,
and I would argue,
I certainly believe for Facebook and I started to leave for Google and also
Facebook.
Of course,
a lot of this data is used to improve the product,
right?
So people are benefiting from it as benefiting as a public good,
not as a private good,
but they get their private benefit from using better products.
Absolutely.
So I think that if we had more targeted direct compensation to people,
we would get larger product improvements.
Um,
I would dispute with you a little bit about some of the numbers.
I've done different calculations then then,
then that exactly.
But,
but yes,
at the,
at the moment things are relatively small I think by any calculation.
But in a future where artificial intelligence really does come to take the role
that investors are pricing into your company and into my company,
uh,
it taking,
I think that if we don't find a way to directly compensate people for the data
contributions that they're making that are fueling those artificial
intelligence,
we're going to end up with a lot of what I would call fake on employment where
people are unemployed but not because they're not contributing value,
just because the value that they are contributing isn't being counted
appropriately.
So,
so if you look at the web writer's handbook,
I was just looking at this a few days ago,
I know several people here,
I've looked at this,
we pay thousands of people around the world to answer questions about page
quality.
That is the labeling that then goes into determination of the algorithms and the
uh,
and the machine learning that helps make the system work.
So,
so there is a direct market and paying people to label and we could do much more
of that for sure.
But the question is,
should it be done through the product improvement side of things?
It shouldn't be done just as a line item on the budget.
We're paying people to rate or evaluate this or label this a material in a way
that helps us design a superior product.
Yeah.
And I think that if more people were aware of the contributions that they're
making and we're getting compensation for it,
you would,
I mean the,
the,
there are absolutely markets as you're describing for those labelers.
They are a little bit sidelined.
And the public image that is portrayed is one in which you don't know.
You're sorry.
You're very right.
I mean nobody knows about this even though it's a easy to check.
Yeah.
I think I think center,
you know,
putting that more center stage and making more people feel like they're
participating in it I think would change the whole feeling of using the Internet
in a way that I think would be productive for our social conversation around
technology.
Well it is interesting how many people write reviews for Amazon and for Google
or for Yelp because people are volunteering this information in many cases.
And I think you might want to argue that,
well the incremental addition to that free service is worth paying for.
And maybe it is,
maybe is,
it depends on how much you're getting people to contribute generously of their
time in terms of doing these evaluations.
Yeah.
Well that's,
it might be,
it's an empirical matter.
Ah,
I'm going to ask one more question and I apologize is a slightly technical,
but your,
your chart on the Labor inverse Labor share and the uh,
and the markup.
I've actually been working on that problem.
This is a paper by a gluten Daluca they are referring to.
Uh,
and it's a little funny because remember markup is the uh,
prize over marginal costs.
Yeah.
So the markup can go up either by price going up or by marginal costs going
down.
Right.
And of course we think costs going down.
Gee,
that's a good thing.
Price going up.
That's a bad thing.
But of course,
by making,
you know,
by moving around these two things,
you can change the level of the ratio of a,
a price of marginal cost.
So in fact,
if you take the formula
in that paper for the markup,
it's also a formula for marginal cost is rearrange the Algebra.
Yeah.
And if you go out and do the calculation,
look at the same data or the same source of data that they looked at,
see costs going way,
way down.
You also see just one,
one last point.
You also see prices going down.
And the question is what's happening is the marginal cost is going down even
faster than the prices are going down.
So
gap is going up.
Yeah.
So I mean marginal costs fell dramatically as well during the postwar period.
Um,
and in fact even more dramatically just productivity,
uh,
when I'm more quickly,
my view is not everything has been terrible in the last few years.
That's not the,
the,
the point,
the point is that if we don't have social institutions that were unrestrained
market power,
that keep up with the progress of technology will fail to realize the potential
that we can have,
which requires constantly breaking up the sources of rigidity that enter the
economy as technology advances.
And I think we did that more effectively in the immediate post war period along
certain dimensions though not all dimensions than we've managed to do it since
then.
So my argument is not everything has just gotten worse.
Of course not.
We wouldn't have had economic growth if that hadn't front of them,
but that we haven't managed to keep up in the innovation of our social
institutions with the innovation that we've had on the technological side.
So let me make one other objection to the [inaudible] work because I don't do,
you just said,
but if you look at that,
the surprising thing from other contributors is the same thing has happened in
pretty much every industry that is labor share has gone down and pretty much in
every country.
Yeah.
So it seems very strange to say,
ah,
somewhere around 1980,
uh,
all these different countries and all these different industries became less
competitive.
It's much more natural to say,
well,
the 1980s,
we had a technological shock that lowered costs pretty much across all countries
and pretty much across all industries is called the computer.
Right?
Microcomputer as we've done and we've seen this technology work its way through
with some leaders,
that is some companies that are doing very well because we've managed to reduce
their costs and improve their quality by,
uh,
using this technology.
We see in other companies that haven't done so well because they haven't done
this to the same extent.
So to me,
the technological hit that reduces marginal costs as much more plausible than
the concentration hit,
which increases prices.
And what I would say is that we had those marginal cost falling before for
reasons that were in fact more powerful than the computer air conditioning,
refrigeration,
lots of huge technological advances except at that time we had policymakers who
were innovating,
coming up with things like the welfare state and antitrust policies and um,
uh,
labor unions that were keeping up with technology.
And in the 1980s,
we stopped trying to keep up with the innovations in social policy that were
necessary to restrain market power within the technology sector.
And that's the reason why we suddenly saw those prices not track as far down
with marginal costs as they should have done to maintain both maximum
productivity growth and about,
so that,
that,
that's a,
but the real debate,
I mean,
there were a question I think is,
is this just difficult to learn how to use and adopt this technology?
When electricity came in,
we saw the same thing happened when Steve came in.
We saw the same thing.
It just takes time for this to work its way through the system.
So you would expect some companies are going to be more productive than others
because they've learned to master the technology.
And two of those companies are represented right here,
Microsoft and Google.
All right.
That's my,
uh,
debate and I'm sure you've got some more,
ready questions coming.
Why don't we start here.
All right.
Uh,
thank you so much for coming to speak and thank you for hosting and providing a
lively discussion.
Uh,
my name's Steven.
So I have,
um,
one question for you on a subject that you actually haven't really touched on
yet,
which is,
uh,
the quadratic voting piece.
Yeah.
Um,
simply because I think politics is sort of the iceberg to all of this.
It's the underlying set of problems to all of this.
Um,
and so I'm,
I'm curious one,
how does that actually work in terms of how does one define the value that each
person is given?
Is it a static,
equal value or can you buy more if you have more income?
Um,
and,
and to,
um,
if,
if you're willing to extend the sort of conversation,
just how do you think the globalization of finance has impacted sort of this
decoupling of productivity in wages that has happened over the past 30 years,
which is,
um,
greatly contributed to the rise in inequality and many of the problems that
you're sort of discussing and thinking about today?
Um,
uh,
on the first point,
it would be not static.
It would be dynamic over time.
People would get voice credits,
they would get a flow of voice credits the same way that they get a flow of a
social dividend,
but it would be equal across all people.
There would be no opportunity you use outside financial resources to purchase
more in less in some much more advanced society.
When some of these other ideas have been implemented,
we have much greater equality,
in which case we might consider allowing people at least at some rate to
purchase more,
uh,
credits.
In terms of the globalization of finance,
look,
I'm not 100% critical of what happened with neo liberalism.
I think that there's been a huge amount of growth in the developing world and to
a large extent that is attributable to the opening up of the international
system to allow opportunities to many more people.
Unfortunately,
uh,
while we opened up to other parts of the world.
I think our economy domestically within the United States and with another
wealthy countries allowed in this greater market power and to,
to some extent,
the external mark three uses a wedge to consolidate the power of capital within
national boundaries.
And so I think we need to rectify that because otherwise we're going to get a
populous backlash that reacts to the fact that things got better abroad and they
didn't get so much better here.
And that feels like something that can be cured by xenophobia,
which you can't really,
but uh,
but you see how people get that logic.
So we need to find a better way to unite the interest of people within the
country and around the world.
Yeah.
So,
uh,
I have a question.
What do you think we can learn from the political failures of the followers of
Henry George and so on and so far as the land value tax,
the optimal policy they were proposing at the time largely,
you know,
ran aground in the Lloyd George Budget and UK,
the House of Lords largely said this,
this Ninjas our interest here in California.
So I'm like pop their teen,
which is largely the exact opposite of an allocator of efficient policy is
impossible to get rid of seemingly.
What do you think we can learn from these failures for putting better policy in
the future?
Well,
I mean,
I think a major problem for Georgia them fundamentally was the failure of the
Chinese revolution because it ended up meaning that.
So Sonia Watson,
who is the,
you know,
founder of the Chinese revolution,
uh,
was basically had the same relationship to George that Lenin had to marks.
And the problem was that,
uh,
you know,
Lyndon was much more ruthless.
He managed to the Bolshevik revolution,
managed to survive and communism spreading everything that became the leading
alternative to capitalism.
And so we got stock in a discourse where everything was about capitalism versus
communism.
And so I think in ultimately,
uh,
if you can have a comprehensive ideology that helps people rethink things like
Milton Friedman did,
he really changed the whole discourse.
I think that we can have a path where,
uh,
people understand and believe in that.
And I think it came close in England.
I think you change a few things and George's,
him would have been very successful in England.
But I think that the communist revolution was a big part of,
of,
of what stopped it.
Hi,
thanks for the talk.
A really interesting point about the concentration of assets and you know,
a few very large asset managers,
money managers.
Um,
my question is where does the political will come from?
Just sort of go after these guys,
you know,
they control a lot and I guess this is more broad Jews,
like they probably have captured the um,
you know,
the congress and you know,
they're lobbing dives are going to be incredibly versus the very diffused sense
among the populous that like,
oh,
it's probably bad to have four companies control it.
The majority of stock in the United States.
Yeah.
So,
um,
first of all,
the most powerful basis of the protection of the,
of Capitol rents is free market rhetoric.
I mean,
it's not just or even mainly things done in the dark back rooms.
Free market rhetoric is something that so many people in this country believe
in.
And if we can deny to the capitalist monopolists the use of free market rhetoric
by saying that true free markets require radical reforms,
radical egalitarian reforms,
I think we can change the political dynamic around these things significantly.
Um,
but,
uh,
second of all,
you know,
it comes from young people.
It comes from students.
That's where,
that's how Milton Friedman change things in the direction that they went in the
1980s,
uh,
capitalism and freedom sold terribly,
among,
uh,
academics initially and it,
and it was very unpopular in the press,
but students loved it and he had a coherent view and it applied to many things
and he really changed the whole political discourse in the country.
So I do believe that the medium term ideas clearly expositive,
uh,
with that tried to directly connect to the public can have a huge effect on
world history.
Yeah.
Oh,
I have a question.
Uh,
I'm a Newbie to economic health politics and uh,
reasons I watched ray Daleo is how economic works in 30 minutes.
Yeah.
So he talks about borrowing and lending and he'd say,
because of that we have credit and these new human nature that we tend to borrow
power off on the future and which lead to some economic crisis because it's a
cycle.
So I'm just wondering,
in your ideal market,
will there'll be economic crisis and if there are,
would there be different a difference in how we address the economic crisis?
So I think that that's a great question.
I can't say that I confidently predict that there wouldn't be crises in,
in the world that I'm describing,
but I think that they would probably be less severe.
And the reason is precisely what you just said,
which is the death and the rigidity is associated with private property as well
are a leading cause of what happens during economic crises.
And in this world that would be far,
far less debt because it would be much less important to take on debt and assets
because the value of all assets would be greatly reduced.
People would be effectively closer to renting assets and therefore many of the
sources of instability that comes from debt finance would be much less severe.
Okay.
Hey,
um,
my question is,
uh,
it seems to me like perhaps some,
products are not
naturally amenable to a constant liquid exchange.
Like may like housing for example,
I might want to live in a particular place for decades at a time.
Yeah.
And if I'm out bid on it and I don't want to leave,
then getting me to do so requires violence.
Um,
or for example,
a physical infrastructure like trains.
Um,
it seems like there would be an enormous cost of the administration of,
of this infrastructure.
We're constantly changing hands,
so,
okay.
I mean,
I think that gives you enough to reply.
So,
um,
uh,
obviously you could maintain stability in this world by charging a higher price
so that it's harder for someone to take something from you.
Now in our present world as well,
stability is costly.
Wealthy people,
they live in safe areas that aren't hit by natural disasters.
They own their houses outright.
They usually don't rent,
et Cetera,
et cetera.
So they in germ enjoy much greater stability.
The poor they rent or they are underwater often with their homes,
either figuratively or literally sometimes living in a very dangerous areas.
And so in this society,
just like in her presence,
society stability is costly.
But the difference in this society is that everyone would have an equal or a far
closer to equal basis to pay for that stability as they desired it.
Then in our present society because you would tax the wealthiest demand for
stability at the cost of the opportunity of the less well off.
Whereas,
uh,
in our presence society,
they can enjoy that stability at no cost to themselves or much more limited
costs and themselves.
Hi,
it's me again.
I have lots of questions.
Um,
so with regard to both the self assessed tax and the quadratic voting,
I'm sure the answers would be slightly different,
but the question and problem that I'm posing I think are quite the same,
which is how would you,
uh,
limit collusion and sort of gaming of such a system in which individuals could
on the self assess tax side,
more or less set a price that is above market that others get by but low enough
to maintain a lower tax.
And then on the political side,
this happens in our elections already.
People running sort of spoiler candidates in primaries or having some sort of
spoil a referendum to try and split a boat.
Yeah.
Um,
how would you imagine that could be a protected against,
particularly when if I were to put more of my energy in one issue,
I would necessarily be putting less energy and voice into another.
So,
uh,
it's more than I have time for it to go into detail about each one of points in
terms of,
uh,
collusion and so forth.
But that's absolutely central thing to the book.
I definitely encourage you to read the book.
Um,
but the short version is all those sorts of problems exist in our present
system.
They are dramatically reduced if not eliminated.
And the system that I'm describing,
so I'll just give you one example.
So right now there's the problem when you have an election of a spoiler
candidate running and possibly,
you know,
messing up the main two candidates,
but maybe even worse.
There's the fact that you can have with two candidates that everyone despises,
but everyone votes for one candidate to block the other candidate.
That's,
I think an even worse problem than the spoiler in this system.
You can show that that's not mathematically possible is what happens is that
because of the quadratic nature of the costs,
if you really hate Hillary Clinton,
you'll vote at least as much against Hillary is you'll vote in favor of Trump
and vice versa.
And so that pushes to candidates that everyone hates down to zero votes.
And so then that leads other candidates to rise up.
So you don't end up with these perverse strategic things where the two leading
candidates get reinforced just to beat the other one.
Wait,
sorry.
Could you repeat the I?
So,
so if you have two candidates,
both of whom are really hated by the other side,
but no one really likes them,
um,
then what happens is that those candidates get negative votes on them.
So they go down to like zero net votes.
And so anyone else who is like not despised ends up becoming a leading
candidate.
And so you can prove that that will lead to it never being the case,
that you just get a perverse thing of two people that are really disliked
winning.
Uh,
just to beat the other one.
yeah.
Back here.
You were,
you were waiting.
Yeah.
Thank you so much.
Um,
how do you think block chain technology relates to the ideas in your book or the
research you've done?
So that's a wonderful question.
Vitalik latera and who's the founder of ethereum just wrote a wonderful long
post about that.
Uh,
which I would definitely recommend to you.
And he and I are writing something together that should come out this week,
uh,
about the relationship.
But a very briefly,
what I would say is the exact technological relationship is complex and it will
evolve.
But philosophically I think they're very closely connected in particular,
both are trying to figure out,
um,
monetary market based,
distributed decentralized systems for ensuring through rules of the game rather
than through discretionary authority,
um,
that we have a more egalitarian distribution of economic power.
Um,
I think a major weakness in blockchain thus far has been that it's been focused
primarily on the cryptographic protocols rather than on the substantive rules
implemented by this cryptographic protocols.
And as a result,
some of the rules of up giving power,
in fact,
she'll oligarchic groups say in China than ended up controlling them.
So they don't really achieve the goals that they're aiming at.
What they need is a substantive set of rules to be implemented by those
cryptographic protocols so that they actually instantiate their goals.
And that's precisely what did Butera and tries to argue in this piece and that
we're arguing together.
So I think that there's a tight unity of purpose between these though.
The actual technological connection is something that's going to need to develop
in the coming years or months even.
So I'm actually speaking at the main of theory,
IOM conference on Saturday about exactly this stuff.
So,
um,
yeah,
go ahead.
Just going back to the previous question to be announced,
I think trying to apply any rigorous mathematical proof to the political system,
especially the American political system is doomed to failure.
But,
um,
yeah,
I think one,
one,
one question I would have in terms of,
uh,
implementation.
You mentioned that like this quadratic voting system seems like extremely
radical.
How,
what are the sort of baby steps that you mentioned in terms of actually trying
to implement this,
especially in the u s
totally.
So,
um,
let me see if we don't have the computer going,
but I can show you afterwards.
We have a nice user interface that even for people who haven't completed high
school,
it makes it very intuitive to do quadratic voting.
And we've been using that to do polling.
Um,
and we've gotten some very interesting results.
We were able to elicit intensity of preference much more reliably than you can
get from existing methods.
Uh,
that's a good place to start.
But the next place that we really want to go is ratings a say of,
you know,
uh,
ride sharing drivers or products online where you have this problem that people
often go into extremes,
uh,
and a lot of sort of troll trolling type a behavior.
And if you made something costly and made,
there'd be real trade offs for people to budget,
to up vote or down vote things,
I think you could get much more reliable and useful feedback in a variety of
circumstances.
But in terms of actually putting into place in,
in American elections,
my view is that once you start using it in some of these commercial domains,
you gradually expand them outwards as people get more used to it in different
domains.
So we greater willingness to experiment in other domains.
Uh,
you know,
blockchain is another place where I think that it's quite likely that this will
be used in some reasonably near term.
Um,
and I think people will get used to the technology.
Like it's sorta like,
you know,
um,
he government happened to a large extent because of all the advances that were
made in the private sector and then those were important into the public sector.
So I expect something similar would happen with this.
We'll take one more question.
Do you have the mic?
Go ahead.
Yeah.
Okay.
Thank you for sharing your ideas.
Again,
I'm there.
I'm looking forward to reading the book.
Um,
you said that the primary of
what you propose is because there is an impending doom almost if we don't do
something about the current status quo.
Yeah.
But do you see this market topia being implemented without massive upheaval?
Because I think what you're trying to suggest is that we need to save our
society almost.
Yeah.
But from the way I see it,
it seems like we almost need to almost throw away society in order to implement
this without like the oligarchies without the current special interests
basically taking control of this or skewing it in a way that basically either
ruins it or prevents it from ever seeing the light of day.
I believe in,
I believe that revolutions are not always,
but almost always more destructive than they are productive.
And on the other hand,
I do believe in the power of democracy and ideas if widely disseminated,
thoughtfully engaged with and uh,
widely understood.
I think public understanding is the greatest accountability against,
uh,
it's special interest capture.
So,
um,
I put my faith in that ultimately,
and I hope that young people,
including some people in this room will build on the transmission of different
aspects of these ideas so that we can keep the broad public engaged and,
uh,
and keep the political process accountable to that.
I think,
you know,
you saw with what happened in the last year or two,
how much desire there is for change,
and if that is channeled in the direction that's productive rather than
destructive,
I think that we have an opportunity to build a much better society.
Uh,
like Franklin Delano Roosevelt,
you know,
I believe did a,
rather than just,
um,
uh,
having a upheaval of island people.
Okay.
Thank you very much,
Glenn.
Yeah.